in other news the Academy Award nominees
were announced this morning with Roma
and the favorit leading the pack with 10
Oscar nominations Netflix received its
first nod for Best Picture with Roma
black panther black Klansmen Bohemian
Rhapsody the favorite Green Book of
stars born and vice are also on the list
vladimir duthiers VAR streaming network
CBS and it's here with the biggest
surprises and other categories yeah I
always love this table
I know what's up this is this is every
every year we say this is gonna be a
tough year this is gonna be a tough year
good morning everyone black panther of
course made history as the first
superhero movie ever nominated for Best
Picture it is also the third highest
grossing film of all time the best
actress nominees are elite C approxi o
for Roma which was her first movie Glenn
Close for the wife Olivia Colman for the
favorite Lady Gaga for stars born and
Melissa McCarthy for can you ever
forgive me over to the guys now
Christian Bale got a Best Actor nod for
his transformation into Dick Cheney and
vice that was remarkable other nominees
William Dafoe for at eternities gate
rami malek for playing Freddie Mercury
in Bohemian Rhapsody Viggo Mortensen for
the green book and Bradley Cooper for a
stars board but Bradley was snubbed in
the best director category guys it's
sort of a big shock has nominated also
for Best Adapted Screenplay Mike Lee I'm
just waiting for spike who received his
first one he the Best Director
nomination for black clansmen he'll go
up against Havel pavlovskiy for Cold War
you're go splat the most for the
favorite Alfonso Cordero in for Roma and
Adam McKay for vice the Oscars will be
handed out on February 24th and we'll be
watching very surprised about Bradley
very happy for spike but I just knew
Bradley was going to get nominate I did
that's the thing about the Oscars there
are never any guarantees but spike has
had such a long career too for him to
receive his first Oscar nomination and
that movie black clansmen is really good
yes it is Regina King Best Supporting
Actress yes for you sir
guitar is for year yeah thank you so
much